naked attraction is the greatest TV show
in
existence I mean beat n how do you beat
that how do you get so many contestants
that's what I want to know I mean so and
it's like a teacher oh yeah lawyer
you're like waa yeah it's amazing so
great oh the music teacher that lady oh
that was a while ago I can't believe you
remember that that's awesome what about
the old couple where the ladies like he
never he never messaged me back he's
like what are you talking about of
course I did she's like he's lying he's
like that's
how you I've never seen the
shot
making I'm totally making all this up
pretty good though would you like to see
that one I would love that